a league of legends twitch streamer
recently dropped out of twitch rivals
after huge backlash from the league
scene over her involvement
things got so bad that three players
allegedly refused to play with her
and then dropped out of the event
entirely why
well the league scene believes that she
falsely accused a pro player of sexual
misconduct
and then never publicly apologized for
it except
she did apologize just apparently not in
the way
everyone wanted her to
[Music]
all right guys what more do i need to
say than subscribe
at this point 2021 is the year the score
esports hits 2 million subs
and we need your help to do it so if you
haven't already scroll down and hit that
little red button for me
alright so your princess was one of a
bunch of streamers picked to be a
captain for
league of legends twitch rivals
scheduled to start on january 11th
the format of the event included a draft
stage with captains picking players
and your princess drafted former pro
mike young
as well as streamers dragoon and ll
stylish but shortly after getting picked
all three announced that they'd be
dropping out of the tournament
here's ll stylish making his decision on
stream did jaden
falsely accuse someone of rape or sexual
harassment
and didn't really give a true apology
after yes or no
maybe i have the i got the wrong story
so far i'm only seeing yes and that's
rare from the chat
that's very rare from the chat well then
this is why i
will decline them mike young didn't give
a reason well
dragoon cited scheduling conflicts and
drama
and we'll get to that drama in just a
second and then league streamer and
another twitch rival's captain
sanchovies also alluded to princess
partly being the problem
on top of a shitty draft format a short
time later your princess jumped on
stream and
also announced that she'd be stepping
down from twitch rivals after a while a
lot of public backlash
was getting mad at other people on my
team for participating
and i don't want anybody to receive any
backlash because of like anything of
people seeing me a certain way
so um with in light of all of the
um people already mad at how poorly the
drafting went today
and my team a lot of people dropping out
although i can
get new players for my team i
want to just make it easier for everyone
and step down
all right that was a quick breakdown of
the most recent news but you probably
have a lot of questions like
i don't know what the hell happened why
are people upset at her
and why are players allegedly dropping
out of this tournament because of her
well in order to answer all of those
questions we need to go back to july
when this controversy first started you
might remember esports and streaming
experienced a wave of sexual misconduct
and sexual assault allegations back in
july
and we covered that situation at the
time over the past few weeks there have
been more than
300 allegations of sexual assault and
sexual misconduct
against members of the esports gaming
and streaming world
and one of those stories came from your
princess who on july 3rd
posted a twitter detailing her
experiences with tuesday
the mid-laner for clg's academy team at
the time and she accused him of making
her feel
uncomfortable more specifically she
describes a night after the 2019
na lcs finals in detroit when she hung
out with tuesday and a bunch of other
people in his hotel room quote as the
night went on some of the players on the
team got tired and left
leaving only tuesday and i alone in the
hotel i asked him if the hotel had any
makeup
wipes because i had glow paint and
makeup on my face for hours
i followed him into the bathroom and as
i was wiping off the makeup
he put his arms around me and this is
when i began to become
uncomfortable end quote from there
princess says tuesday allegedly picked
her up and put her on his lap
she says this is when she asked him what
he was doing and reminded him that he
had a girlfriend
the rest of the twitlonger talks about
their friendship the alleged rumor that
she tried to get tuesday to cheat on his
girlfriend with her
and the fact that this entire situation
made her feel quote
really uncomfortable end quote a few
days later on july 8th
tuesday posted a nine page response that
shared his perspective
tuesday says that they exchanged flirty
dms over the years and says that he was
surprised when she described their
friendship as platonic
he then shows a bunch of dms from her
asking if he was single
and telling him that he was cute on the
day of the finals he then says that on
the day of the
incident the two were excited to see
each other and spent most of the day
watching the games together
from there the response gets into the
hotel room after the
after party tuesday disagreed that the
two were ever alone he denied ever
grabbing your princess and putting her
in his lap
and then he showed a direct message from
someone who was allegedly there
saying they also never saw this happen
he then says that they flirted some more
but it never went anywhere
the rest of his response is dedicated to
the aftermath and apologies
the aftermath is tuesday talking about
how he felt ashamed of that night
and how it jeopardized his relationship
with his girlfriend in that section he
also says that he never started or
spread any rumors of your princess
trying to get him to cheat on his
girlfriend now based on the new
information that tuesday gave in his
response
the league scene responded positively
and largely sided with him
since then many have accused your
princess of lying about the incident of
conflating this situation with some of
the more severe allegations of sexual
misconduct that were surfacing at the
time
of not dealing with this more privately
and they said that she should apologize
to tuesday
for attempting to ruin his life and all
of the controversy that we're talking
about right now
is what ultimately led the three players
and your princess
to drop out of twitch rivals now on july
13th
a few days after tuesday posted his
response your princess released a
short one-page statement clarifying a
few things in light of the growing
backlash against her
i was very naive instead of pushing to
resolve the issue offline
i posted my original statement online i
was not painting tuesday
to be a rapist or abuser nor was i
trying to cancel him
what i was trying to point out was i was
put in a situation that made me feel
very uncomfortable
flirting is not an open invitation to be
touched and often times women are blamed
and gossiped about in ways that can feel
earth-shattering at the time
end quote alright that was everything
that happened in july that started
all of this controversy now leading
through the next five months
up until now whenever your princess
would tweet
or just be on social media in general
people would be in her replies demanding
an apology
or calling her a liar and then riot
announced on december 15th
that your princess would be playing in
an upcoming league of legends all-stars
event
people still pissed off over what they
saw as false accusations and a lack of
an apology
were pissed off all over again that riot
would choose to include someone with
this kind of controversy hanging over
them
and then a few days after that because
of course there's always more documents
your princess put out a 15-page response
to the response tuesday put out
five months ago in july and just to
hammer this point home all of this
controversy
is seen as the reason why mike young
dragoon
and ll stylish refused to play with your
princess
and dropped out of twitch rivals but
let's get back to your princess's latest
document
she says that she was quiet over the
last five months since july
due to all of the backlash she was
getting from the community
she apologized for the timing of the
release of the original twitlonger
but not for its content she says that
she never meant for the announcement to
allude to any instances of sexual
assault
but she does stand by the fact that
tuesday did make her feel uncomfortable
she then doubles down on tuesday getting
her to sit in his lap
provides more context on the flirty dms
and then concludes with this
quote i've always tried my best to have
a positive environment for my stream and
all of my social media i am sorry to my
friends family and community that have
received any verbal harassment or hate
i'm going to take what i have learned
these past few months
and continue working harder than ever
for my community friends
family and myself end quote and all of
this brings us back around to twitch
rivals and your princess
as a captain when it was announced that
she would be participating league fans
were pissed off again
because they felt like the controversy
still hadn't been properly addressed
and they felt like twitch was ignoring
the scene's concerns they were also
upset at the fact that twitch and riot
chose to promote
this person instead of another woman
league streamer of which there are many
to pick from
even the draft didn't go smoothly with
multiple people reporting that twitch
had banned the use of the word
tuesday from the chat and people were
pissed off over what looks like a twitch
staff member
apologizing to your princess on her
stream
ultimately people are upset over what
they see as exaggerated and false
accusations
a lack of a public apology and the fact
that twitch and riot gave a platform to
a person
they don't believe deserves it
[Music]
[Music]
you